kevin van hordes elder scrolls online
why in the goddamn hell you writing an
assassin robe it's an assassin's creed
rogue Justin Calvert got this for me
isn't it great it's wonderful great
repentance I can also wear it at home I
won't just wear it here you should maybe
not put it on oh yeah I guess I need the
microphone right I feel like the optimal
place to wear this is probably at home I
wonder if I can dramatically really do
it I've never tried this before but con
the next Assassin's Creed game you play
as Kevin Bernard also it said in san
francisco in the modern day oh no none
of those oh yes Napoleon had am i that
part of thing that's happening it's
great the chickens have large talent now
the scores online elder scrolls online
that's what I'm here to play actually
back free to play above no no no no
that's not a busy but fools we can say
whatever we want on today's show is the
best part oh look there I am as you do I
have to look over there alright so kevin
van noord that is welcoming one told van
noord see the my problem is I'm not a
Nord so I don't know yeah you don't be
misleading to miss Leigh wait a second
this is first person what's going on is
his first person it's all these Scrolls
mattel these Scrolls lightly to be fair
most most MMOs actually let you play
them in furniture but you never seen a
weapon no you never this this is
interesting like you see it over they've
they've obviously put some some effort
into the first person so for example if
I try to like tumble like that's what
you see in first person as opposed to
the Grand yeah that was way better sand
tumble that was way better not tumble
animation their first person like that
yeah yeah show me another 10 total
forage is this like unreal tournament
i'll tumble for you yeah see see what I
did there I made a culture club
reference this nobody gets to eat yeah
wearing a wearing golf got it yeah
people are people like yeah I totally
get this game be way better if your head
top view point of Utah toppled around in
a nauseating circle every time you did
this oculus rift no no probably better
than fan or give me the skinny on
not jump everywhere I go and actually
earn fact are jealous feel for that
which is which is kind of sad you have
leveled up that was my that was how I
played morrow in love jumps everywhere
and you be over encumbered rivers pretty
you can't you it this actually just has
an inventory limit okay Kevin I would
love to sit here and spend the next 20
minutes talking about how this isn't
Skyrim right you just tell me give me
the skinny on the other schools are
shining wizard I am a sorcerer i'm
playing a high elf sorcerer okay i'm in
the Daggerfall covenant so so that that
and i have a guild so if you want to
join i forget the name of the kid that's
got what's the name of the guild the
vanguard Nords is the name of my guild
so you should apply for that in the
meanwhile it's so let's get into some
fighting right sewing do you have a pet
did you summon I familiar I do have a
pet thank you daddy's who's fixing my
mic Oh lurcher goes I do that's your
client that's a clan fear that well I
got can you just look at that again dude
I've got clown fear all the time that
looks like one of those little sewer
sewer dinosaur chickens from Deus Ex it
does that's exactly what it looks like
but i also don't lawyers on the phone i
also have a couple of uh of cosmetic
pets that i can pull out if i can
remember exactly where they are at or
it's hard to see from from here I only
have Kozma here we go so I have like
beautiful butterflies that perch on your
shoulder no no I've got an Englishman
which is so basically I've got a monkey
a lizard and a crab so so mud crab mud
crabs Cutler and there's a dude behind
you are you gonna get PvP dright now no
that's not here I could go to the pvp
area but it takes a little bit of time
thats Sarah daler eyes if they're Sarah
dill is is the pvp area it functions its
it's in the Dark Age of Camelot Global
Washington vain okay glee demons on fire
give me that I want the blank canvas on
this or are we just in a place now we're
basically we know everything about mmos
because Warcraft minutes along or what
what new is Elder Scrolls online bring
it to the table here well I think part
of it is that it has a really great that
the questing is really great number one
in this game that's that's the thing
that I like the most is that most of the
things are not sending you out saying
kill 50
this kill you no guilt I know that yeah
collective I everyone pelts they're
actually doing a really good job of
giving everything some context so for
example this I'm just coming through and
fighting these things but I've been
through here before and and when I first
did this I I helped the weird sisters oh
yeah so they're basically a bunch of
witches that are that are you know that
use the term weird to describe this all
with why yes
so Anna and you get lots of chances to
make decisions okay so for example I had
a quest in which of a man had stolen a
mic of a necklace okay from his mother
whoa who give to his servant girlfriend
right but when the mom found out then he
denied it and the the woman was was the
servant girl was thrown into the tower
right and left to rot basically wait
Angie how did you fix the servant girl
sonu she was dead I had to talk to her
ghost oh I had to decide was like it was
I gonna break the curse so that the
family would be set free okay or would I
actually enact her revenge oh that's
good so there are there are those
moments where you get to do that as far
as I can tell there's no there's no
grander um you know there's no element
of that where their grand consequences
for a lot of that stuff in one mediate
cons that kind of is often more
enjoyable because then you don't feel
like you're playing a gay it doesn't
feel gay me it's just like a moral
decision that and also you're not
waiting for some distant pay off all the
time you're yeah you're getting your you
feel like you're doing stuff you feel
like you're you're you know living a
life hmm right another interesting
aspect of the game is the lack of
interface as it were so you're playing
at first person now do you actually
tends to play in first person or you
just do it as for our sake it all
depends sometimes I play in first person
just because it's Elder Scroll DS and I
like elder scrolls II yeah I I like the
way some of the spells look in first
person when I'm playing or not there are
other times when I'm up against enemies
that do that have attack cones okay
there you have to get outside of the
cone or you have acrobatic enemies that
are leaping over top of you and stuff in
that case I play I like to play third
person because I can't always see the
extent of the damage cone yeah a little
bit more situational awareness they just
run into a bog and get his horse eaten
by an alligator well the horses are kind
of an interesting thing I'll get on my
horse you saw on your horse I'll some of
my level do
need to be here we go I quite like the
whistle get it right away one gold buys
you your first horse really oh so horse
economy is just totally bottom that then
get horses and you can feed your horse
to to help his stats oh can you come one
of the stats be flying no sadly I
thought you're gonna say you can feed
your horse to elder on enforcing your
horse but there is the sad thing about
horses they do tend to be a little bugs
sometimes you're just like you know
you're you get into water and suddenly
my horse will just disappear even though
horses are supposed to be able to like
cross marshes and things like that I
also had another interesting bug the
other day it was actually part of the
weird sisters quest line where suddenly
people were speaking in German great and
I was talking to Justin Calvert who's
also playing the game yeah he he
mentioned that for him it was it was an
English the way it was supposed to be
that's great so random German I'll go to
what's up just show us the map show me
how big it is and here's some but one
while do you do that Gatling eglington
in the twitch is asking me how much a
month is this game this is 15 bucks a
month ok cool first month free oh yes
first 13 so this is just sub game yeah
or so purchase of game before yes so 40
buck first month 60 bucks fifty bucks
it's it yeah it cost fifty bucks I think
and then fifteen dollars a month and you
there are some pre-order bonuses where
you get you can unlock a race for an
entire race race for a pre or when I
sock your eyes the nose at the red card
is it okay I wrong about that I could be
wrong because the code that I got is all
of that stuff like I got all of the
deluxe edition so I wasn't quite sure so
you started off in a this is all of the
game this is all of Tamriel de un floor
you can even go to where the alt merry
elves are from but in this case I can I
can fast travel but I'm gonna I think
have you been to Skyrim at no no I have
not been the sky oh I have to get there
before I can fast travel to do it places
but daggerfall because I'm part of the
Daggerfall covenant that is the first
that is the first city that I went to so
I'll go ahead and travel to daggerfall
so people can get a nice cool what
daggerfall looks like is that based on
your race or your covenant you chew okay
which does have some you know in my case
any any race as any race in class I
could be a member of any covenant I want
any of any of the three factions so as
far as I know there are some limitations
for people who are not who did not get
the collectors edition stuff so here are
here are here's daggerfall it looks way
better than daggerfall looked well
that's because the mayor dagger Dale
yeah yeah he's weird man that dude like
that whole crack video online and stuff
look man he was doing skooma yeah
remember that I was there's a lot of
pressures on the mayor you know and if
the city the streets are clean they're
pretty clean what he does in his spare
time who's to judge is they're all like
psych questi stuff Allah Elder Scrolls
like is there a thieves guild is there a
dark brotherhood stuff there is right
now I'm a members of the fighters guild
and the mage guild I don't hang out I
don't know yet if there is a if there's
a field I don't know what the dark
brotherhood present okay like goat quite
yet but that is a sheep that's a goat
seat on see it's a goat seat you see I
don't even get anything for that but
yeah there are there are side quests and
whatnot as well and once you join guilds
I can show you this once you join
certain guilds then you can you get
access to certain certain skills that
you wouldn't have had before like in the
fighters guild now I can start leveling
up these particular things once I nice
once I do enough quests for the guild
and so on and so forth you know mages
guild here and and and so forth is that
bit at the bottom the 1 2 3 4 5 that's
sort of your hotkeys of the skills that
you have yes that's absolutely right now
that's absolutely correct are you happy
with 5 or is this a game we like five
plus i get my my super skill here and
there's also another skill that i can
attach to the key watch your super skill
can you do with another goat i can let
me but let me find something to fight
it's more fun like an actual goat as
opposed to a sheep which dennys goat on
calling a goat we call this go to run
from goats on the brain right i mean
that's all we really definite
don't you know there's one that I left
here I'll have to go I'm here that's a
dear you aren't actually waste no my
skill no no no don't do it okay I'll
find a more longman hang on i'll try to
this game looks pretty great it really
does seem looks good yeah I'm a caveat
that would for a first actually you know
what no for an MMO it does look it's
really good but it actually looks kind
of all right anyway it looks pretty good
yeah I mean just by any standard it
looks nice it doesn't it's not breaking
any technological barriers no so pretty
you know it but it is pretty it has that
elder scrolls style but once you start
looking at some of the nitty-gritty some
of the I mean this is Elder Scrolls
right Shirley animations aren't exactly
on top of the line as it as it were
which is which is my way of saying the
animations are pretty mediocre overall
but you know so in motion the game isn't
as good as when it's stationary which
again is sort of an elder scrolls that's
just Elder Scrolls history right now to
make the animations look good would be
denying the history of other Scrolls
that is that hold true when you start
talking to somebody like their face yes
a little bit it's not it's not as quite
as wonky as it used to be that zoom in
on their faces really weird there it
does zoom in on their faces that they
don't they look pretty natural but the
lips the lips ticking isn't all that
great here we go I want to get you a
couple more questions your scroll back
and twitch ask Kevin how much does the
game feel like a proper MMO do you
interact with others and the is group
content meaningful um I've done some
grouping not a lot of grouping yet I've
only I've only done some Oh see I can't
do my thing it's it's on cooldown we'll
make sure with your other thing a lot of
people aren't of it anyway yes you do
get a chance to do that but I haven't
done any dungeons i have done pvp we
could always move over to pvp real fast
weight or we end if somebody sort of
wants to see a little bit more we've got
a bath reformulate interaction time work
while you do that I got a couple more
questions why tune up wanting gamespot
child asks why's it such a delay between
the pc version the ps4 version and do
you think the melee combat is better
than Skyrim is in no i don't think the
melee combat it better than scarem i
would actually rather play skyrim's
melee combat than this the combating
this feels like MMO combat correct
Robbie there's more like mmm oh
that then Skyrim does I do like being a
spellcaster I'm trying to get into the
queue for PvP it does feel like a more
like an MMO than typical like elder
scrolls because there's this sense of
you know your actions aren't necessarily
being seen on screen is one to one I
press the button and the thing happened
on the screen the way you would normally
expect there's also a hang on getting
into there there's also you know the
cooldown aspect it's probably a little
bit greater yeah um in the MMO you'd
have to wait for things and you're not
actively blocking shots and swinging
your sword back are you it's not like
you were blocking in you do block but
again this stuff seems a little bit more
hot baarish ya then typical Skyrim so it
kind of finds his middle ground it's not
it's not bad by any stretch but it does
lack some of that immediacy of offline
Elder Scrolls so here we are and uh
let's give you an idea what the map in
Syria looks like oh it's here that's not
it's tight but no no that's not it's not
quite it is the imperial city or there
is that's what i can do is i come in and
i can activate the shrine and now you
see what it more or less looks like
that's not Alli factions fighting this
as you see the map is mostly red red
team is winning yes absolutely so that
would be the ebonheart pact that's
that's that's red what a bunch of drag
us all is blue and you see poor yellow
is just having a tough time now this is
early access so i suspect that we'll
find think because right now a lot of
the the pacts the you know the factions
are choosing you know are choosing maps
that are going to favor them so i think
this stuff is going to be a little more
evened out once we get into and while
you're doing that a couple more
questions real quick fire be Hardy are
there giant rolls in this video game i
haven't seen any giant trolls i didn't
see much of giant anything and there are
no dragons and I'll man is my understand
he'd gamer asks and how big as the world
had to verse is the landscape so far it
seems is big and diverse as I would want
from an Elder Scrolls game but you know
it's hard to say right now how it's
going to compare because I haven't it's
like Golder suppose you have to get
around you have to unlock the places to
really get a sense of yeah
sure much diversity there is I will say
that I feel like Skyrim had a lot more
immediate diversity at like a watch as a
question it'll be close to your heart
does it have a bang in sand track like
the other scroll game is it's quite
beautiful yeah it's not as far as I know
it's not the work of Jeremy Soule who
now exclusively works with SOE when it
comes to MMO oh really so yeah that was
part of the everquest next announcement
is right it when it comes to MMOs Jeremy
Soule will only be working with SOE for
at least some period of time ok I'm
trying to get to battle so maybe I'll be
able to get to a battle before and
before we have to go and inject Jackson
to Jermaine asks a question which you've
probably touched on already in terms of
the combat have they improved hit
detection and third-person combat
animations it it's better than in beta I
would say they definitely put a lot of
work into it what I say it's up there
with something like like Tara or or you
know net even neverwinter I wouldn't I
wouldn't put it up there no I would say
that Tara still has the the best action
combat of an MMO at the stage still when
you talk about action combat you mean
like sort of like well wildstar does as
well that that hole where you were
swinging and how you are attacking isn't
just yeah what you what you do is what
you see ya is more or less you know kind
of the action combat that's a lot of
these games are going for now I think
that elder scrolls finds itself in in
and in between where it sort of gets
some of that and sort of doesn't so
that's where the combats awkwardness is
lie sometimes it feels like it's really
nailing it yeah other times it doesn't
quite feel like it's got that that sense
of impact between what you're doing and
and what is actually happening on the
screen Evan are you doing a one man for
trade no I'm trying to catch up to where
hopefully I'll have this goes I'll have
some you know so right now I'm trying
I'm trying to get up there so you're
gonna wait oh I see yeah Justin I'm not
sure if we're gonna get there yeah we
were there cuz if they're trying to see
it for daddy asked another user question
will be their moment to ask Evan a
question of my own
you were obviously playing this at the
moment for review and whenabouts area
you have the review up on about games
bub I don't know you like to but the
good news is well I mean people can can
join in in the process because I'm live
streaming my play every most every day
there's something that I'm doing so the
best way to find out about that the best
way to find out about that is here we go
now I'm getting some other players which
is good news you can use some horse
murder like dying I could try to murder
that guy you just send a monkey after
him that's my that's my nothing out
non-combat oh I don't remember monkeys
being and I was coming at you with the
axe Kevin don't get axed Kevin you're
getting axed I'm getting totally yeah
that's all your blood coming out you are
defeated PvP by the way does put you all
at level 50 so there's I and that was a
that was get a guaranteed loss on my
part I mean I kind of need especially
with one play like that yeah I wasn't
and I want play wasn't wasn't too
exciting but yeah on gamespot you can
find it's called the Elder Scrolls
online live stream extravaganza and you
can watch it there you can just follow
me directly on Twitch which is my
twitter user name is kevin van noord my
twitter username is fiddle cub so i was
announced this stuff so you'll either
see me tweet about it or you'll get a
notification from twitch when i when i
load everything up and get ready to go
so tonight 528 is the scheduled time
okay that's pacific so which means it's
specifically at five in a civic pacific
so specific before we let you go and can
i ask you one more question or ask you
rather what's how you feeling better
right now one once two sentences how you
feeling about ESO everything is true
nothing is permitted no that's all
that's on the rocks are liking about
something else now you early it's so
it's it's decent right now I don't
really have a good sense of whether this
is going to be the game i go back to
time and time yeah but it nails that
elder scrolls by but on the other hand
it's fine sort of an uncomfortable in
between it's not quite Elder Scrolls
because you don't have quite as much
freedom yeah and it that that comes
across in lots of little ways that I
started to really miss okay guy rim in
Oblivion
marwan for that and it doesn't quite
nail the MMO bit because right now the
game's not doing anything to really
encourage me to be with other people
yeah so I'm more interested in following
the story and exploring the world on my
own than I am in getting together with
other players so I'm curious to see how
that evolves it's early times cool
obviously so but but yeah I'm having a
good time so I can't thank you very much
for coming on we'll be back